hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today I'm going to take you
through the history of humoral miasma
and German theories so basically these
are three different theories they're
three different ways of understanding
the spread of disease let's start with a
humoral theory
so it was dominant from ancient times to
the 1800s especially in the Western
world so when you think like medieval
times in Europe or the early American
colonies humoral theory is really how
people thought disease spread they
thought that disease was caused by
imbalances and foreign different bodily
liquids these were blood phlegm black
bile and yellow bile and each of these
liquids is associated with with
different temperaments with different
seasons but ultimately it was thought
that to have good health they had to be
balanced in a particular way and so
there were treatments that were aimed at
restoring the balance of these four
humors treatments like bloodletting with
leeches the use of laxatives also a
medics to make someone vomit blistering
of the skin or the throat things that we
know today are usually not helpful in
treating disease and they were just
trying to restore the balance here and
unfortunately often did really more harm
than good
now the next theory we're going to talk
about today is miasma theory it has also
been dominant in various places from
ancient
times two about the 1880s and so even
when the Western world began to give up
humoral theory they were then
transitioning to believing more in
miasma theory miasma theory held that
disease was caused by something called
miasma which was basically bad air sort
of filthy stinky gross air given off by
rotting organic matter and you can kind
of see how this made sense if there's a
lot of rotting dead bodies dead mice and
the road a lot of sort of human wastes
and feces that make things smell really
bad a lot of unwashed bodies cramps
together in cities that stink those are
all situations where there's a lot of
disease spread as well of course we now
know today that it's not just bad air
it's not just that smelly air makes
everybody say but this is really what
people believed in through the mid
eighteen hundreds in the late 1800s and
it had it sort of upside and that it led
to improvements in sewage and general
sanitation in major cities for example
one year what's called the year of the
great stink London smelled so bad the
Parliament couldn't even meet because
the air just smells too foul and so
because they also thought that that
horrible smell caused disease that led
to a lot of sort of sewage and
sanitation improvements in cities which
was a really good thing now let's move
on to talking about German theory
so germ theory is basically the modern
understanding of disease it gained wide
acceptance in the 1900s
after miasma theory was debunked
although as we'll talk about in a minute
there was early evidence that predated
the 1900s that was still in support of
germ theory germ theory says that
disease is caused by microorganisms or
microbes hence the name germ we have
about germs are talking about microbes
now there's a couple of caveats to keep
in mind one is that this is talking
about infectious disease only so
diseases that are caused by by bacteria
by fungi viruses we're not talking about
diseases caused by more genetic and
environmental components so things like
genetic disorders or cancers or or
diseases from exposure to pollutions or
toxins we're not talking about those
types of disease we're talking about
infectious disease and so infectious
disease is caused by microorganisms so
this is the modern understanding of
disease it's not caused by imbalances of
humor it's not caused by smell the air
is caused by microbes now this they'd
have to be updated so in the 1930s when
viruses were first being understood
viruses are not technically organisms
are not alive they're not considered
micro organisms and so the germ theory
had to be updated to be infectious
disease caused by microorganisms and
viruses it had to be updated again when
prions were discovered prions being
infectious proteins I know let's talk
about some of the early evidence for
germ theory as early as the late 1600s
we had a scientist Anton van Leeuwenhoek
who developed an early microscope and he
was the first person to actually see
bacteria under a microscope
he called them animal kill a or animal
cules which her face is basically sort
of latinum for tiny animals in the 1850s
we saw some public health efforts from
people who thought you know this miasma
theory it doesn't make sense to me
so people like Ignaz Semmelweis who said
no
then fever it's killing all these women
who have just given birth it's not
caused by bad air
I think it's caused by physicians not
washing their hands so he made people
start washing their hands and they were
delivering babies and sort of
post-delivery
infections went way down around the same
time John snow was looking at the
cholera outbreak in London and London
health officials said it's definitely
bad air and Johnson said that doesn't
make sense
I think it's dirty water and he actually
was able to trace it to the Broad Street
pump and prove that cholera was a
waterborne disease instead of an
airborne one in the late 1800s Pasteur
disproved spontaneous generation this
was the idea that living things could
come from nonliving matter he said no
they can't there's these microorganisms
that we can't see and then around the
same time Robert cook was developing
what are now known as cooks postulates
which are the set of rules we have to go
through and satisfy in order to say that
yes this disease is caused by this
organism and so all of these sort of
advances towards germ theory really
predated it's its final acceptance in
the 1900 so that's it today if you're
interested in these topics about
epidemiology and disease spread please
see my playlist for those types of
videos you can learn more about Koch's
postulates you can learn more about
various types of diseases and the way
that they're transmitted vectors things
like that so check that out and thanks
for watching biology professor